Trascrizione:
Questa è Blue Marble,
ed è la prima immagine
che abbiamo del nostro pianeta
completamente illuminato dal sole.
Dagli anni Settanta
è diventata un simbolo,
soprattutto per gli ambientalisti,
della fragilità, della bellezza
e della vulnerabilità del nostro pianeta.
Io, ogni volta che osservo
questa immagine,
vedo un pianeta unico e straordinario,
di cui siamo ospiti,
e tutte le volte la guardo e -
Mi ricordo che dallo spazio
si vede solo il blu degli oceani,
e il verde delle terre emerse:
non si vede l'impronta
degli esseri umani, la nostra impronta.
E quindi, per me, questa immagine
è diventata un simbolo
per ricordarmi che anche
senza di noi, noi esseri umani,
il nostro mondo continuerà
comunque a esistere,
continuerà comunque il suo moto
attorno a sé stessa e attorno al sole.
La prima volta che ho scoperto
che il ponte tra uomo,
e natura, si era rotto
è stato in prima elementare
quando, passando accanto al mio pratone,
ovvero il campo accanto a cui
passavo tutte le mattine,
ho scoperto che, di lì a poco,
sarebbe diventato una strada provinciale.
Per me, per la Sara di sei anni,
quella era la più grande ingiustizia
che l'uomo poteva commettere
nei confronti della natura.
Quindi ho deciso di attivarmi,
e con l'aiuto dei miei genitori
ho scritto una lettera
al presidente della Repubblica.
Per me quello è stato
il mio primo atto di attivismo,
il mio primo atto di attivista,
anche se poi alla fine
non sono riuscita, comunque,
a impedire la distruzione
di quell'enorme pezzo di verde,
come vediamo in foto.
Però per me è stato
un po' il mio primo passo
per voler proteggere
la vulnerabilità del nostro pianeta,
così ben rappresentata, anche,
nella foto di Blue Marble;
una vulnerabilità e una fragilità
che è anche una vulnerabilità nostra,
perché tutte le volte
che accadono degli eventi
che sottolineano quanto l'uomo
abbia abusato del nostro pianeta,
ecco, io mi sento fragile,
mi sento vulnerabile.
Secondo me tutti noi
dovremmo scoprirci più vulnerabili
e dovremmo riflettere
su quanto abbiamo distrutto
il ponte tra uomo e natura.
Io mi sento molto spaesata
quando, ad esempio,
accadono degli eventi
che sottolineano questa cosa,
come ad esempio
la distruzione del pratone;
ma anche gli incendi in Australia,
che hanno colpito
tutti noi lo scorso anno.
E io, tutte le volte che mi sento fragile,
che mi sento vulnerabile,
mi inizio a chiedere
se effettivamente ha senso
anche solo investire nel mio futuro,
proseguire gli studi
o provare a cercare una casa.
Ecco, gli scienziati di tutto il mondo
hanno creato un orologio climatico,
il Climate-O-Clock,
che è questo che vediamo qua
e che segna quanto tempo
abbiamo ancora per agire,
per contrastare la crisi climatica
ed evitare i cosiddetti
"punti di non ritorno".
E a me, onestamente,
questi dati mi fanno riflettere,
mi creano un'eco ansia, un'eco paura;
e secondo me tutti noi dovremmo avere
un po' di eco ansia,
un po' di eco paura verso il futuro.
Una paura che però non ci paralizza,
che però ci aiuta ad agire
e ci permette di creare, anche,
delle soluzioni per il futuro.
Io sono di parte,
e credo che tutti, forse, dovremmo essere
dei piccoli attivisti per il clima,
che usano la propria voce,
le proprie scelte,
ma anche e soprattutto
la propria quotidianità,
ma per creare un futuro
migliore e più equilibrato.
Come? Noi, banalmente,
abbiamo tutti in tasca uno smartphone,
e tutti noi possiamo provare
a scaricare moltissime app
che ci permettono di calcolare
la nostra impronta ecologica;
e quindi anche migliorarla,
e anche provare ad avere
un impatto minore sul nostro pianeta.
Ci può aiutare, anche,
a fare una raccolta differenziata
nel modo corretto;
e inoltre, il nostro smartphone
ci dà anche accesso
a un sacco di informazioni,
informazioni che possono essere usate
per fare una piccola ricerca
sulla sostenibilità,
sia ambientale ma anche sociale,
di aziende o anche solo
di singoli prodotti.
In questo modo possiamo essere
dei consumatori più consapevoli,
e avere un reale impatto
sul nostro pianeta
e migliorare la nostra impronta ecologica.
Poi, citando Aristotele,
"L'uomo è per sua natura
un animale politico",
e come tale deve assumersi
la responsabilità del bene comune.
Tutti noi abbiamo una responsabilità
verso gli altri e verso il nostro pianeta,
ed è una responsabilità
che non si può demandare agli altri.
È una responsabilità
verso la comunità in cui si vive,
verso la Polis.
E quindi tutti noi abbiamo il dovere
di migliorare il nostro territorio.
Tutti noi possiamo votare,
possiamo indicare la direzione
dei nostri rappresentanti politici
nelle decisioni,
e soprattutto scegliere
i nostri parlamentari;
e in questo modo
possiamo avere un reale impatto
sulla nostra comunità
e sul nostro territorio.
Però, la domanda che mi viene
fatta più spesso è:
qual è la differenza
tra una persona che fa tutte queste cose
e un attivista ambientale?
È che un attivista ambientale
prova a creare del dibattito,
prova a portare il dibattito
nella propria quotidianità,
quindi sia con gli amici
che con i parenti,
ma anche e soprattutto in ambito sociale.
È un agente del cambiamento.
Io credo che senza il dibattito
non si possa avere la consapevolezza,
e senza consapevolezza
non si può avere un mondo migliore,
non si può provare a migliorare il mondo.
Quindi io vorrei dirvi
di parlare di questi temi,
e anche se parlando
e interessandoci di questi temi
ci scopriremo, inevitabilmente,
più vulnerabili,
io credo che questo sia il vero modo
di creare un vero cambiamento.
Quindi scopritevi vulnerabili,
non abbiate paura della vostra paura.
È solo in questo modo che potremo ricucire
il ponte tra uomo e natura,
che si è rotto;
e creare, appunto,
un mondo più equilibrato.